and um i'm just fascinated that's what
like when i see marshall warfield or
somebody mm-hmm at the common store i
always go up and say hi
yeah and go welcome back i know but
really what happened in pineapple
express
we'd actually love to know it's like a
running a running discussion of your
trailer
i feel like you were disrespected in
some way
i don't take responsibility for any of
it by the way
we should run it back people are
supposed to manage you correctly
but what happened what happened episode
one i think was dedicated to your um
the pain you felt of what pineapple
expressed i think so i think we
dedicated a whole episode what what pain
you shared you shared pain and
anger towards that
oh okay
they didn't have a trailer for you
that's what i heard
but let me just say one thing when i
heard you say that first of all i want
to be honest about it because i don't
want you to feel i don't want you to
feel bad about it but i am a super
people pleaser
there's nothing i want more than every
actor or crew person to feel very
respected so the idea that you showed up
and they didn't have a trailer for you
no no no you have it wrong
everyone in the room has it wrong okay
all right here we go it's your side so
i was a crybaby yeah
all right so let me just apologize i'm a
little [ __ ] baby
it's baby so you guys had trailers for
me
every time i was there except for one
day yeah okay
and that was the day when you guys had a
lot of people
just shooting that day you had
i don't know 30 or 40 [ __ ] people
that are on the cast list you know the
big fight scene yeah it's chaos right
production is chaos right and you guys
said to me for one day
can you just stay here with these people
yeah which happens to be the extras it's
fine
say that one more time more believable
that's never okay
no
it was with the um background background
the right background in which i made
very good relationships still talking
very little never don't know what they
look like okay so our numbers were wrong
we didn't realize how many people were
there we didn't have the room for you
and if every person there we thought you
were the one who would take the hit
okay we could have done it to ken jong
we could have done it but you did it we
could have done it to craig robinson or
kevin corrigan or gary cole there were
so many people there but for some reason
they went down that sheet and they said
let's let bobby sit
with all the with the extras oh god
atmosphere all right so
you're right but i made a mistake yeah
and i made a call to my agent at the
time
and from what i heard not from you
but from somebody else that was involved
in production that he raised his voice
and he was angry at us
not you specifically but he called us
angry yes right and i go why did you do
that you just made a big deal out of
nothing
in fact i left that agency after that
not right after that but like six months
after that my point being is is that we
made a complaint
um
and secondly here's another thing that i
[Music]
you're just like me i just want to say
this is why i like you
like the description of like cleaning
the poo remnant off the side of the
trailer toilet like most people you know
mel gibson's like cleaning off the side
he's just like someone will get that
later right me and you are like let me
get that i can't and there's no one
we'll never we'll never we'll never meet
the person that cleans it or
the whole production but we will do that
yeah yeah we will alright
what you are lying to judd through your
teeth he wouldn't clean it he would
never i he would call me to come over
and clean it that's a fact there we go
he is not his he is not he doesn't this
is 2007 bobby lee okay thank you
who cared more and i just want to say
something to you yeah my my girlfriend i
mean all right is is that
um when i do that right it's not because
of for me and my i care about my
environment i care about whoever has to
clean it after me and whoever maintains
those trailers so i just didn't want
them to see that i
had pooed
he's also put in the back of our prius
and i've had to yeah
on a frisbee on a frisbee on a paper
plate as well and i've had to collect
that okay
but the key question is where does it go
right after i threw it in the dumpster
and this is information that i don't
think mr judd appleton
that i put in my prius
but was it because there was nowhere to
go i have well during the pandemic let's
here's a good example
let's get into this
um nobody you couldn't just walk into
any establishment and say can i use your
restroom everyone was like nope our
restaurant thank you so we were outside
of my dermatology um office and i was
like for the love of god please do not
poo he's like i have nowhere else to go
so wait a second but you can have like
your pimples popped
but he can't poo
in a
public toilet thank you correct so what
i did i was like
nice one you know what that's not just a
little side note before we even continue
that's why i love this guide man i know
there's always little details yeah yeah
little details to back my uh background
i'm gonna offer you a compliment because
this time around he put down a trader
joe's bag before he put on top of it
before that he would just bare back it
yeah and go right into the oh jesus the
car upholstery
um this time around he did sync to put
something underneath and then he packed
it up himself and then where'd you put
it yeah i went to the nearest outside
dumpster and sometimes they're locked
right i didn't put it on top i found one
that was unlocked courteous thank you so
much and i double bagged it no one
smelled anything let's move on from it
okay it's funny because with poop right
you have different phases of life where
you you feel differently about it like
yeah periods of your life where like
it's shameful and the door locks and you
clean up and you don't want anyone to
know what happens but then there's other
moments in your life where like you
literally could just lift your leg like
a dog
and not care and understand like living
in the woods and just like why do we
care why are we ashamed
you know yeah yeah give me a [ __ ]
frisbee exactly what i wanted to say i
couldn't articulate it as well
[Laughter]
i don't even know if i said articulate
right i don't think i don't think i did
right but that's thank you so much for
doing that my friend but what did you do
with pineapple express that you're
ashamed of oh god this is your room
now you have to reveal it all right so
and this is so shameful for me and it's
so funny because
the ad
right is the same ad that does a show
that i'm on called reservation dogs on
fx
and um i apologized for her about this
to when i saw her when i worked with her
is so
there was a scene where i got shot in
the head by seth rogen
in the movie
oh i feel so shameful
and afterwards they go
just lay your body down here
because we need it for you know
what do you call it um
you know the word continuity continuity
that bodies always have to be there
right but there were some angles where
they were shooting wides and stuff i
just knew
for a fact i'm not in the shot
we made you later all day right
yeah yeah so i like that this
is considered a nice thing i did for you
impactful yeah impactful thank you for
that
this helped the career
yeah
so there was so there was a time like an
hour or two in
a couple of setups i just stood up and i
go i'm not laying there anymore
right and they're like well it'd just be
better if you did
and i remember being kind of a [ __ ]
about it and it's just something that i
would never do now
like i would lay there for three days
how long was it at that point how long
like on and off i mean at the end of the
day probably at 30 minutes better
question is like you look pretty it's a
relaxing thing to do why wouldn't you
just lay there a little longer well that
probably the fake blood probably gets
all gooey thank you
this flies stuck to it but not only that
you don't understand that there's a
metal plate in my head
oh there was a metal plate in my head
because they had to put an explosive on
the other side of the metal plate
they're laying on the metal yeah so when
they're shooting me right there's an
explosive right so now i'm laying
not only there's sticky blood but
there's a metal plate into my brain so
is this the thing you're ashamed of that
you got up
that i didn't sit there forever and i
apologize okay well that's actually
those are two things you know how you
know we were abusive to you
and you've said this before and i
disagree go ahead is that
you got up
and we were like all right
you know like we didn't meet you
you weren't in the shot
right can i tell you something that's
like terrible about maybe the early
stages of my career go ahead there is
nothing i would have found funnier than
to make you lay in blood all day off
camera telling you you're on camera i
wouldn't do that now but as a young
person
so you [ __ ] knew no i'm saying i
don't think that's what happened yeah
that's the kind of thing that would have
made me laugh like bobby doesn't even
know he's
[Laughter]
that is pretty funny like we did uh you
know uh happy gilmore you know with our
friend alan covert
and
we made him play a
homeless guy
and
so he we told him like you can play the
homeless guy but you have to start
growing a beard now like six months
before the movie shot yeah but really
the whole idea of him playing a home